there was a female comedian celebrity i
will say the name at the end because
it's more fun as a revival
okay good that a couple two years ago
when there was the giant fires in malibu
um i saw her post on her social media
that there was a bunch of animals
trapped at the malibu wine safari
like trapped in the fires couldn't get
out yeah so
i was part of a search and rescue team
just because i'm a canadian and this is
what we naturally do
um so i went and i told the search and
rescue team hey i just got
this tip about this look at this story
truckloads of us went up into the
mountains
during the fires with these giant animal
crates we were like oh we have to rescue
this giraffe we have to get all these
animals
so we have to get all these big animal
containers that they usually use for
zoos or to transfer animals
there was i think there was like 10 or
something of us going up there
it took an hour to get in through the
fires
we get there ready to rescue these
animals
and they were fine
one of the things that i love about you
is that you've been open about your
evolution and you've just kind of gone
where good people are and that kind of
thing which is very
very much what i did as well like you
just kind of like
well wait a minute all the bad guys
actually seem like the good guys and the
people who are always telling you
they're the good guys they don't seem
that great or that tolerant
or that diverse or anything else but
i've never done this on the rubin report
before but i would like you to pick up
your phone
right now okay and i am gonna ask you to
quote
yourself we're gonna we're gonna put up
we're gonna put up the image but i want
nicole arbour to do her best nicole
arbour impersonation because i believe
it was the day before the election
am i right the day before the election i
think it was the day before
like two days or maybe two days before
you put up a post on instagram that i
thought just absolutely encapsulated
so much of why people that you would
never
think traditionally would have voted for
trump or would have voted republican or
conservative
why they did it and so now nicole arbour
this is nicole
arbour as nicole arbour here we go
go team okay that was my impression of
me okay
i said and i meant this i said because
one day i'll be telling my grandkids to
stand up for what they believe when i
didn't
because i believe black people can vote
however they want and speaking down to
them
is racist because i am and will forever
be against censorship of any kind
it's dangerous it's wrong and it's
anti-american
because democrat-run cities are falling
to pieces like a zombie movie
because for four years i was called a
trump supporter as an insult
i wasn't at the time but it was used as
the worst thing you could call someone
and a quick jab by people who call
themselves
liberals the way they treat anyone
different with oh the way they treat
anyone with different views is actually
discrimination
and isn't liberal at all it's gross no
different from not liking someone
because of their race or religion
because logic over feelings because i
grew up admiring the american dream
and he's the closest choice to restore
it for everyone
not just those who say the script and
fall in line ah here comes the good part
because most celebs are full of [ __ ]
because peace deals and new partnerships
because he stood in the face of lie
after lie media hit peace after media
hit peace he was a flawed leader is
refreshing
real because he didn't start a single
war because biden sniffs little girls
and is clearly unfit
mentally to lead a boy scout troop let
alone a country because trump will lead
north america not just america to the
best four years we've seen
and because my friends and family and
you can disagree and i'll still be cool
with you because this side allows
conversation
that's kind of how giant peace deals
were signed i'm nicole arbour i'm a
libertarian and i endorse donald j
trump for president yay
nicole you do a fine nicole rooting
myself is hard i started sweating
yeah but that right there and the way
you did it
like just so human and real and like not
like i'm this
crazy extremist and all that stuff i
just
i really just thought it was perfect and
yes when you give it to the celebrities
who are
just so full of [ __ ] i mean i live in
this town
i live in la i know these people they're
not good people
they're just there's not they're going
to tell you
i have one story i don't know if i
should tell you tell me if i should tell
it you must there's a female celebrity
that a lot of people know
oh here we go all right here we go all
right
there was a female comedian celebrity i
will say the name at the end because
it's more fun as a result
okay good that a couple two years ago
when there was the giant fires in malibu
um i saw her post on her social media
that there was a bunch of animals
trapped at the malibu wine safari
like trapped in the fires couldn't get
out yeah so
i was part of a search and rescue team
just because i'm a canadian and this is
what we naturally do
um so i went and i told the search and
rescue team hey
i just got this tip about this look at
this story
truckloads of us went up into the
mountains
during the fires with these giant animal
crates we were like oh we have to rescue
this giraffe we have to get all these
animals
so we have to get all these big animal
containers that they usually use for
zoos or to transfer animals
there was i think there was like 10 or
something of us going up there
it took an hour to get in through the
fires
we get there ready to rescue these
animals
and they were fine they were never at
any point in danger
it was a lie he was totally social
justice warrioring
all over the interwebs and the zookeeper
was in tears this tiny little mexican
man that this is his whole life
he's in he came out running in his socks
crying and he's like please stop taking
photos and stuff with my animals and
pretending that they're being abused
this girl came here earlier said she was
going to try and help raise money for us
to rebuild because the buildings were
burned down but not the animals
and she took all these selfies and stuff
and he let her and then she released
them
to the press as if something bad
happened to these animals and they were
abused
i came back i felt so bad for these
people i came back the next day with the
press
walked around with the fire chief who
said that
the place was so safe he would have put
his men where they had their animals
during the fire
um the spca came with us uh all the
press came with us and walked around the
entire property to show
what she had said is a lie because she
was whole business
turns out she had a personal vendetta
against the business it's whitney
cummings
so this does not does not surprise me
yeah well i listened to her and i put
the lives of like 10
it was like 10 to 12 people our lives
were literally in danger we knew that it
was a scary situation
and i saw her post and i believed her
and i went into the [ __ ] fires
to save all these creatures freaking
noah's ark over here
and they were fine and then she wouldn't
tell the press that she
had exaggerated she's like well there
was blood in his nose i'm like yeah
the draft got a nosebleed because there
was a fire around him it's dry
and then she called and apologized to me
at one point and said you know
i i shouldn't have responded like that
to you
whatever and i'm like okay we can be
cool again me being canadian
then i meet her in person and she was a
total douche bag to me
as if it was my fault for revealing that
the thing she made up wasn't real
and i'm just like geez these social
justice warriors are
[ __ ] you almost killed people
because you have a personal vendetta
against the wine safari like whatever it
was
yeah it started for me there i'm telling
you
can we do a little bit of the the what
happened to comedians kind of thing we
talked about kimmel a little bit that's
just like
that's like late night tv a certain set
a certain level of them
but like what the hell has happened to
comedians there are like
basically no funny comics anymore i want
to do some stand-up stuff with you we
were talking about it before this
you know and then the whole stupid
lockdown thing but like watching some of
these people that used to be
funny sarah silverman cummings
uh it happens to uh amy schumer like it
happens to be a lot of females but it
but it's the men too i mean they've all
look pat and oswald
all of these people that have just gone
totally bananas
like did you see it coming did you see
it coming
i didn't see it coming i didn't and it
like for a little like i don't know if
you can see who's over my shoulder
this is like my wall of heroes oh yeah
uh
god if he was alive right now
they'd be saying he's an old white rich
man i mean that's what they'd be calling
him while he'd be fighting the power
accurate that's fine um i
kind of love everything that's happened
to stand up and to comedy
and this whole like everything is wrong
stand up for
blah blah blah shut up amy schumer
showing up to
the woman's march with your supermodel
friend to pose in her belly top saying
don't objectify women while she twerks
for money in a thong
shut the [ __ ] up all of you shut the
[ __ ] up
get out of the way but because they're
so crazy it made a new breed of comics
and i'm so happy i swear like the day
after the election
i saw all of the comedians just kind of
like snap
all the really good ones i'm talking
like andrew schultz god he's
he's so good um i'm talking like who
else like chris de stefano do you know
him i don't i don't oh
you need to you're gonna love him
i saw them kind of like snap too i saw
all these comedians just like this
little spark wet in their eyes like
we give up we've been we're okay we're
going
and everyone's just been like going and
it's been really fun to watch and i
think it
cracked people to where comedy is just
gonna go
boom again so you think we'll have a
boom in comedy because it was
so bad and so you know social justice
virtue signaling lefty nonsense
that you think after now we're gonna
have like a second explosion like an 80s
explosion or something
oh yeah i i'm thinking even someone like
a john crist i don't know if you know
him
oh people really knew him for more like
kind of christian comedy and he kind of
stays in that like hilarious and witty
safe space
of the christian comedy his last like
eight videos have just been
lethal and he's just like going after
the leftists and i'm like okay
like everyone is just starting to hammer
on it because it's so ridiculous
and i've decided i have like thrown out
all my other plans for 2021.
i'm doing a late night show good i have
multiple offers
thank you do it i'm excited i have to
come on yeah i'm just gonna go right
with them i'm gonna take them out i have
offers from multiple networks right now
and uh we'll see where i land but
i'm out for blood i'm gonna take him out
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about comedy
instead of the non-stop yelling you get
everywhere else check out our comedy
playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're both
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell